[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you for listening uh please hit
the Subscribe button I really appreciate
that you know the bigger the show gets
the bigger the guests get the more we
can do and then I also start to feel a
path for what kind of people you want to
hear from so today's show is with Evan
Britton former NFL player who played for
six years he is now transitioned into a
yoga teacher he wrote a book called the
ebb and flow basic tools to transform
your life he also has the ebb and flow
podcast someone that is so masculine but
yet learned how to sort of balance with
the feminine aspect of him and look
these are the answers This Is The Answer
girls and guys I love listening to how
men work so
I think you're going to be just as
interested but men this is it this is
where you really get the answers to how
to really find happiness in your life
because what you'll hear is that heaven
was miserable physically mentally
emotionally and he tells how he got out
of that and what the important things to
do are I'm I'm really waiting for
someone to be able to articulate this
stuff as well as he did and he's such a
great Storyteller too so make sure you
listen all the way to the end for one of
these great metaphorical stories that
we'll just I think it will resonate
deeply let me know what you think in the
comments are there any expressions in
football that you use on some sports
there's always like you know
Expressions right like funny ones that
you guys all know I love you so many
that I I couldn't that's such a great
question but I don't know if I could
think of them off the top of my head and
some of them are probably not
those are the ones I want yeah yeah yeah
of course
something about girls or something about
like you know kicking someone's ass or
you know any of those kinds of things
let them let me marinate on that and
I'll come back to it that sounds good
we'll close with some disparaging
comments and things that you want to
hang that phone up from yeah things that
you've evolved Beyond yeah perfect
really I mean I'm a huge football fan
always have been then to come across you
some time ago
um to go from football to being a yoga
teacher and like being spiritual and
talking about it it's just um it's
becoming a slight bit more popular
um but definitely
um you know you've been doing a lot
longer than most and so
um I'm really fascinated by that and I
think ultimately like the core question
is is how how do because I was thinking
I was like what's the what's the
question the question is how can a man
still be a man and
uh but also be in touch with his
emotions and be able to communicate and
still be strong like how can you be
vulnerable and strong at the same time
because that seems like the really big
gap with men they
or even I don't really understand how
that can be but I feel like you've
figured it out
I guess so
um that's such a good question Danica
and uh
you know it's something that
I've been asked called
whatever you want to call it
to speak on masculinity more and more
which is interesting to me because I
never really thought about it that way I
never thought about anything I'm doing
as driving towards
articulating what masculinity is in a
time when men feel seen to be completely
lost in that and what that actually is
I did a podcast with my brother
a few weeks ago and it was masculinity
and that's how people can listen to that
um it occurred to me that as we were as
I was stumbling through attempting to
Define what masculinity is it was
becoming really clear that masculinity
isn't really something that we can put
words to like we can say it's being the
king it's the mountain it's
being the provider all of these words
that don't really
paint the picture of what it actually
means to be a man who's living in
his who's living anchored in his
masculinity anchored in his what I would
say his Divine truth of his soul
and um it's really something that needs
to be expressed it's something that we
see when it shows up in our lives
you know it's not really something that
we can talk about necessarily in a in a
way that makes it make sense
um I've been reading this book
it was on it just sort of popped out to
me on my bookshelf it's been sitting
there for a minute
that's what they do they call you and
then they call you to finish them at the
right time too usually exactly and it's
a book by Osho
intimacy
and uh I'm a big fan of Osho I love Osho
and uh this book I started reading it
like
a year ago and put it down it wasn't
really making sense exactly
and then I picked it up again and it's
completely right on time as it is
so funny how that happens I mean it's
not funny it's just it gets more normal
when you get in the magic of stuff
absolutely and
um
he's so powerful and he says he starts
talking about intimacy as something that
all of us really need on a soul level we
really need intimacy because otherwise
we're just floating through the universe
completely alone
and everyone we come into contact with
is a complete stranger really because
we're just functioning through these
masks yeah it makes sense these layers
of identity you know of how you relate
and who you're supposed to be and what
you got to say and what you got to do
and and
he starts to say that while it's
something we all desperately need on a
soul level it's also one of our greatest
fears to be seen because we think that
the moment we're vulnerable or the
moment we reveal Our Truth to another
being will be completely destroyed yeah
and
for men I think in particular
we've really been carrying that belief
around that if we reveal our inner
happenings to the people around us we
will be completely destroyed and we will
lose everyone around us
their faith will lose their trust will
lose their connection
and he goes on to say that which has
been the the experience of my life is
that
only the person who meditates can be
truly intimate and what he means by that
is through meditation you come to terms
with all of the dark hideous things
inside of yourself that we all have in
there these things that we really don't
want to acknowledge these ugly truths
about who we are deep down Underneath It
All
and until we come
to be friends we reconcile those places
in ourselves
we can never really be intimate and for
me this whole process of becoming the
man I am today and putting me on a
trajectory to be the man that I'm
destined to be in my life which I would
say is still a work in progress
undoubtedly
that Journey started through meditation
and through this practice of going
inside and learning about who I am
Underneath It All
and
I think that you know men are in this
place we've got
you know we've really hammered the money
and power and as success model and
clearly that hasn't
fulfilled Us in the way that we believed
it would like for me playing in the NFL
achieving this dream that I had from the
time I was a little boy
achieving that dream making millions of
dollars making more money than anybody
in my family had ever made having all
the stuff I could ever want being able
to take care of everybody I've ever
loved in ways beyond my imagination
there was still this hole inside of me
the thing that everybody's been telling
you as a man that you're supposed to do
with money and power you got and it
still was it almost kind of puts a
magnifying glass on what's not being
seen right it's like I've had those
moments in my own career where it's like
you have these sort of existential
moments where you're like what's the
point of all this because you realize
when you could buy what you want do what
you want you're like but something's
missing yeah it makes it worse almost
exactly well that's he tells this
incredible story I'm not going to talk
about the Osho book the whole time but
he gives these incredible
examples of for instance Alexander the
Great this incredible Warrior this
historical figure who is a conqueror of
the whole world from a young age
and at the end of all of his conquering
he had done everything he could possibly
do on every battle on every war
conquered every land he had come across
and there's this story that his
his followers came and found him weeping
in his room by himself one day at the
end of all of it and they're like what
are you doing dude you're crying like a
little baby what's the what's the matter
with you you're the you're the king of
the world like what are you doing and
he's like
it means nothing
it literally means nothing that I did
all of this you know like all of that
commenting and fighting and War and this
this rampage that I was on to conquer
the world literally didn't mean anything
when it comes to me feeling fulfilled in
my heart and my soul
what does it mean if you were to put a
meaning on it what does it mean then
is it really completely meaningless or
is there something to to to say about it
all of these things these external
things they're great you know they're
they're great Endeavors for us to take
on some more so than others you know
these
these passions that we have it's all
good it's it's a it's a trick of the
mind that we get attached to the things
that we're doing and assign
we assign the importance the meaning of
our entire life to the thing that's what
we do
we are meaning making machines
everything absolutely so it's like my
football career that was it man that's
the mountain I'm gonna climb that
mountain once I climb that mountain I've
done it I'm here I've achieved
everything I've looked to achieve
to achieve and then I get there and I'm
like oh [__] there's another Mountain
over there
that I haven't even started climbing yet
and I think that's probably the mountain
that'll get me to where I need to go
because there's something missing here
still
you know and
for me it's always come down to
this thing of
becoming whole because that's for me a
big part of what it is like becoming
whole feeling fulfilled
feeling at peace
inside and
that's another thing that's difficult to
articulate because I could say
take care of yourself you know listen to
what you need go you know jump in the
ocean do breath work go do a yoga class
connect with your loved ones all of that
stuff is good too but then again that's
just another little thing that we're
assigning all the meaning to that's
supposed to fill us
fill our cup fill our heart and make us
feel whole but it's really that's one
moment The Human Experience is so vast
we're gonna continue to feel like no
matter how much you meditate no matter
how much yoga you do breath work
Ayahuasca all this stuff no matter how
much of that stuff you want to do you're
still going to feel
so then it becomes something very subtle
it's this very subtle practice of
constantly tuning in to
the heart to your insides to reconciling
all these parts of yourself
well and emotions are emotions will
always be there
thousand percent and Duality is seems
pretty pretty inherent to this reality
it's completely inherent and
the practice has to be
getting good with all of it
and I was talking to this guy the other
day and he said ebb man
you know I've got my meditation practice
down I do my breath work I get my
workouts in I Journal I eat well I've
I've gotten sober I'm total I've
radically changed my life
I'll be walking through the park high as
a kite
living on the joy and the light of life
and one negative thought comes in and my
whole day is [__] up
what do I do yeah and I said well this
is where the practice of loving it all
comes into play
like that negative thought comes in
can you learn to be an acceptance of
that too
because those thoughts are always going
to be there you know like I said we do
all this stuff the feelings are still
here yeah wow we're never extracting
ourselves from that so the practice then
the [__] real practice you've
established this great foundation and
all of this stuff is really important I
mean I wrote a book about it you know
talking about the tools that have helped
me create some stability in my life
coming out of a lifetime of [__]
mental and physical chaos
you know there are tools that bring us
stability and peace but then it becomes
something much deeper and something much
more vague to be honest because it's
about what's happening one moment at a
time and how what's your relationship
with what's happening these things come
up and you have to you have to get to a
place where you have a consistent calm
way of dealing with the thing that comes
up that's negative
um
I'm I'm wondering like what did you have
to turn off or what did you leave off or
turn off now that you have some
hindsight from your career as a football
player when you were doing that versus
what did you have to turn on or realize
like I'm wondering kind of what that
Delta was and maybe there was a an event
an impetus to sort of catapulting you
into the space that you're in now that
is you know seemingly a big departure
from where you were
um you at least have done a lot of work
and so was there a moment or and and
then do you have hindsight as to like
this hurt me and this is what's helping
me I finished playing football in 2014.
that was a roller coaster because it was
this initial feeling of immense relief
like I had it I had done the thing I'd
set out to do I'd given this game every
bit of me that I had and I had nothing
left to give there was no more rage
inside of me and I remember that very
vividly there was a moment in Chicago
it's such a it's such a big story and
this becomes a podcast in itself I'll
give you the cliff notes my last year in
Chicago it was the bye week I had flown
back to LA because my high school was
retiring my jersey
after the ceremony I'm watching the game
and I'm literally doubled over in agony
thinking of food poisoning or
I can't tell what's going on I'm feeling
awful basically like cold sweats knifing
sensation I got really feeling really
bad hmm
and so it took two days because
I suppose you could say it's the cliche
stubborn man of I'm fine I'll make it
through I don't need a doctor
but it's the day we're supposed to fly
back to Chicago and I I say I don't
think I can get on the plane I need to
go to the emergency room go to the
emergency room I've a ruptured appendix
I need to have an emergency appendectomy
I end up staying in the hospital for a
week
I lose about 25 30 pounds have to call
the team a week later I fly back they're
like yeah I'm gonna make weight now
just take it easy I had to have a blood
test every couple days to make sure all
the toxic matter was out of my
bloodstream I was on antibiotics and all
sorts of stuff and painkillers and
they're basically like yeah but there's
maybe six or seven weeks left of the
season and they gave me a month of just
lifting weights there they said Ed just
lift get your body back take it easy
yeah you still need to recover so I was
in there watching film lifting weights
really taking my time getting my body
back
so fast forward finally I'm back
practicing
and I'm sitting there in the film room
one morning
and I'm watching myself on film I'm
blocking this defensive end
and it was like this tidal wave
realization of
what in the hell am I doing here what am
I doing
I'm in pain from the top of my head to
the tips of my toes
I gotta pop pills just to sit in this
chair
I'm here thinking it's glorious
and this coach behind me God bless him
doesn't give a [__] if I left right now
he'd plug somebody else into my spot
it wouldn't matter to him at all
there's a million places I'd rather be
yeah you weren't happy I used to want to
kill that guy that I'm watching myself
block and I was like I had none of that
left I have none of that left in me
and
I knew right then I was like I'm done
I'm done with this I've given this
everything I have because you know it
was your last year or you're just
referencing it because it was
it was my last year yeah I know but did
you know it was before the moment no no
no no no you're just referencing it
because it was but you didn't know until
that moment that moment was my last
that's when I knew I was done okay and
so at the end of that season
interestingly enough I I got a letter
from the league that I failed a drug
test for Ritalin
which is a whole other story you can
watch the documentary on take your pills
uh it was a good documentary it's on
Netflix if anybody's interested in
seeing that story but I had been on a
therapeutic use exemption for Adderall
taking Adderall for
much of the time during my career and
then one day especially a guy like you
how much does a guy like you have to
take for to stay to have Adderall work
oh my God I was taking way too much
Danica that's a miracle I'm alive
honestly
um I was taking way too much Adderall
but you know my body had totally broken
down and Adderall had been this really
great way or really powerful medication
to lift me up out of this Haze that I
had been living in
cognitive decline I had a really bad
back did that you take that the whole
time you played all six years in the NFL
after my
that started the middle of my second
year okay I was dealing with a ruptured
disc in my back and excruciating sciatic
nerve pain and it was the thing that
Lifted Me Up out of a really dark hole
and I was grateful for it at the time
and then of course I just became
completely dependent on it and couldn't
function without it like God forbid I'd
sit in a meeting room without some
amphetamine coursing through my system
so it was a day I'd come back from this
Hospital
appendectomy experience
I was out of my Adderall prescription a
guy on my team had Ritalin I thought to
myself
treats the same thing you know if I get
drug tested
if I get drug tested I'll just have that
I'll just say hey I had to take a
ritalin because I was out of Adderall
and they didn't go for that so that
letter
of
they said that he tested positive for
Ritalin abandoned substance under the
you know yeah CBA whatever you're gonna
have to serve a four-game suspension
next year and it was this super clear
message from Spirit going AB you can be
done you can be done
so your question was
what was the difference
or what was the moment what was the
Delta between
turning whatever off that was running
that show turning something on that's
running this show and
you know so I came out of football and
it was this big relief at first because
I think to some extent ninety percent of
guys
I would say
I mean I'm sure you can relate to this
Danica ninety percent of the athletes in
the NFL I'll speak from that point of
view from the time you're a freshman in
high school you've got this thought in
the back of your head how long am I
going to do this when is this going to
be done and for football in particular
because it's just this pain game it's so
rough
people have no idea how beat up you all
get
and they don't I mean I know that you
crash into each other but then you're
back next week and yeah you're doing
spectacular things and whether you guys
get beat up all the time I mean you're
playing with little broken toes or giant
bruises on your foot or your leg or your
arm and cuts and that's just like the
daily yeah that's just what you're
dealing with every day you're just
playing football exactly
so there's always this thought of like
when am I going to be done when is this
over when am I going to be done putting
myself through this thing
so that day had come for me and I'm
really blessed because there's a lot of
guys who are just grinding it out and
the game just spits them out when it's
ready you know when it's done with them
for me I was
the game had kicked the [__] out of me
I'd kicked the [__] out of myself and I
had exacted I had released all of this
rage that was the motor behind me being
who I was on the football field so there
was this relief of being done but pretty
quickly that descended into holy [__]
who am I what am I going to do with
myself what's my purpose
how am I going to make money I have no
life skills I can't relate to anybody
outside of this this lens of me being
the Superstar athlete I don't even know
how to have a conversation with somebody
I don't know how what to talk about I
don't even know what I like of course
yeah knowing yourself is not as easy as
it sounds it really isn't especially in
this world in this realm that we find
ourselves in where you've got you're
constantly bombarded by social media and
advertising and marketing and all of
this stuff and then you lay on top of
that your parents and your family and
whatever there's always people around
yeah there's thousands of people we come
into contact with who are feeding us
ideas about who we are and what we're
supposed to like and do and be like and
all that stuff
so here I am and
my entire life is just crashing over me
and around I guess it was
2016 end of 2015 beginning of 2016
somewhere in there somewhere between the
end of 2015 and fall of 2016. I was at
complete Rock Bottom all of the Escape
valves had stopped working the two hours
in the gym
the smoking tons of weed the bottles of
wine the porn all this stuff it just
wasn't working anymore it wasn't
bringing me any relief it wasn't helping
me escape
the way it once had the dopamine hits
just weren't needy had to keep climbing
and there's nowhere else to climb to
exactly
and I was confronted with the
the reality of my life I was confronted
with the reality of myself can you break
that down to like a wound or like a a a
negative thought that you had or
something that you knew that you had to
go to work on it culminated with me
screaming into the phone at my wife
saying I'm going to kill myself or I'm
going to kill somebody as I drove on the
on-ramp for the 170 to go to the CBD
company I'd started you know by the time
I got to the office I could barely speak
I could barely breathe my mom called me
because God bless her my wife at the
time ex-wife now love her to death she's
the best amazing mom she had gone to my
mother's house in tears and was just
like I don't know what to do that's
completely flattened and I don't know
how to help him I don't know where he's
at and
um
so Mom called me and said hey Ed how you
doing I could barely speak you know and
uh she said hey why don't you come over
for dinner
I was like all right mom we'll come over
so I go over for dinner that night and
it's my mom
my aunt her twin sister my godmother and
my brother
Gus and
they just start talking about our family
disease of alcoholism and how
the chaos that I was brought up in
has really informed all of my decision
making for all of these years and how
I've been struggling is really tied to
this family disease and we have tools
for that and it's called 12-step
programs
and for me so dinner was an intervention
get caught on camera but it was an
intervention
pretty much and in the mo and you know
I was there I was completely surrendered
because
and that's an important part of this
thing when I'm talking to people
it's an important part of this process
to hit rock bottom and one of my great
mentors he said
in this life it seems like there's two
ways to evolve through Insight or
through pain
and a lot of people they need pain to
grow and for me I had to hit rock bottom
and get to the place where I was like
okay
give me something just tell me what to
do right what's the one um I want you to
I don't want to break your story up too
much but I just think it's important
because
Rock Bottom is so arbitrary
but is it and so if you had to put words
to what
what is the final thing that you're
you're not getting anymore or you don't
have or you're not feeling or you are
feeling that could be a common
denominator and what's considered rock
bottom
I can look myself in the mirror anymore
I couldn't look myself in the mirror I
felt like if I didn't change how I was
living and how I was existing
it was either change or die that's where
I was so you weren't worth being around
anymore basically it's kind of like you
were like where's I'd have no worth left
yeah and
you know that had come through the Stark
realizations of a lot of recognizing a
lot of
chaos a lot of damage that I had reaped
on my life the people around me
people are super close to me like doing
a lot of damage in those relationships
that sure I couldn't look at myself
anymore if I didn't change how I was
doing things I've read something a long
time ago that's so true it's just it's
that when people shut down or numb out
um or are in communicative about what
they're feeling what's going on it's not
that they don't have any it's that they
have so much that they don't even know
where to start it's actually
overwhelmingly
vast as opposed to nothing
a thousand percent and that was my
experience I've been thinking lately how
grateful I am to be in this place that I
I'm at through
seven eight years of
slowly but surely putting myself back
together yeah and the clarity and the
peace that I experience on a daily basis
that's so sustained by some miracle of
God and really it's just the miracle of
the discipline
you know it's the miracle of having
discipline
in the meditation in the yoga and all of
that stuff but also the miracle of the
discipline in learning how to love
myself
and learning how to fill this
hole in my heart
that
has been filled and then it comes and
you have moments that feel completely
lost I'm like I don't know what to do
and then having those tools to just be
able to get quiet and see what do I need
here
do I need help do I need to reach out do
I need to call somebody
um and like you said
that insurmountable pile of things
that's swirling in your mind
and that's like
the credit card bill and the
conversation you had last year and when
you snapped on your partner and when you
know you hit the dog and then you broke
the glass and you know it's like all of
these things
you know and then it becomes like
spilling the milk is just a complete
disaster
and I come from a family that
a goes to war to solve problems
so that was normal too that was my that
was my programming yeah so you actually
are you're actually trying to get to
that place not consciously but
subconsciously from a programming
standpoint that if it's not drama
and what it then it's not it's
uncomfortable it's not working right if
it's not [__] up and hard and
and somebody's bleeding at the end then
we didn't do it right you know
football
yeah exactly so you know I got to go
through this really incredible process
so I went to this first Al-Anon meeting
Al-Anon is for families of Alcoholics I
never had a drinking disease but I had a
thinking disease like mine was all about
my relationship to my thoughts and fears
I bet that's so similar for so many
people with addictions yes big time so
much going on up here it's not it's a
coping mechanism
thousand percent and
um so I went into this first meeting it
was a men's meeting which of course
uh was really important and Powerful for
me and it was sort of unknowingly you
know I didn't really understand the
significance of that necessarily at the
time I mean I thought okay it's a men's
meeting
I definitely missed the locker room and
being around the guys and my football
team sure
but I didn't necessarily take into
account oh these are gonna be men who
uniquely understand
the situations of yeah my life yeah
and I go in there
feeling all sorts of things
and the first guys the lead share starts
to speak and he just starts talking
about
it's as if he's talking about my
childhood like everything I went through
my parents got divorced when I was seven
I had to become the alpha male of the
house or I took on
the role of being the protector for my
mom and my brother and my mom descended
into her drinking and really struggled
and
she relapsed and I there were [__]
crazy people coming in and out of the
house and all and I just like I was
codependent I was the one who had to
keep everybody together I had to make
sure everybody was safe like I took on
this whole role at the age of seven yeah
that I've been carrying with me
throughout my life yeah self-abandoning
for sure oh that I'm I was a master of
that the master self-abandaner which is
you know it's what's really you know
shocking when because you end up get
giving a lot of
um you know uh foreign
type and the uh not codependent but
avoidant and narcissistic that they're
the bad ones but the codependents are
just as bad because we're doing it oh
yeah I say we because I have been
codependent in the past too is that
we're looking for something too
totally nobody's no streets clean on
either side an interesting Paradox the
woman who started Al-Anon Lois Wilson
who was Bill Wilson's wife she was
married to the man Bill who started A.A
and The Story Goes that
her whole marriage she's looking at this
guy and he is a Fall Down drum bad drunk
so bad I mean this guy went to see Carl
Young and Carl Young said maybe if you
find God there might be a miracle for
you to get sober but I don't really know
how to help you don't know where to go
from
car yeah so
Bill actually met a doctor named Dr Bob
and they together formulated AAA the
12-step program because the whole time
she was going when he gets sober our
life is going to be changed our life is
going to be better
and then one day he got sober
and she realized holy [__] I have a
whole part in this madness that I
haven't even
realized was there yet so she had to
start Alan on what is the element about
Al-Anon that makes it different than a a
so Al-Anon is for AA is about you have a
problem with drinking your brain
chemistry changes when alcohol comes
into the system with 12-step programs AA
in particular alcoholism it really short
changes
the accessibility when we use the term
alcoholic because there's a lot of
people out there
who
you could also I I you can also equate
alcoholic to narcissists you you are
completely blind to how your actions
words behaviors affect the world around
you and you don't give a [__] about it
so you just continue drinking and using
and doing all of this stuff just like
laying waste to the world around you and
all your relationships without a care in
the world now the Al-Anon
the Al-Anon is really like
so it's not about a substance but many
guys who get sober they end up going
into Al-Anon because Al-Anon has the the
emotional and mental component of how to
start existing as a human being who's
striving for more peace with just
alcohol or any addiction or is it just
is it just about your fundamental sort
of like life upbringing patterns that
they're helping you understand
yes is it like Hoffman
I don't know what Hoffman is Hoffman is
kind of it's like excavates your entire
sort of yes programming yes that's what
Al-Anon really does it's it's about what
is your relationship to yourself and
your life and
identifying what's dysfunctional yeah
and identifying
new ways of being sure so what was the
one that you were like what was the
thing that came through that you were
like
oh [__]
I mean so much honestly
uh you do this thing called a step four
and for me my sponsor had me write out
my life story
from my earliest memory oh God that's a
lot to the current moment wow and you
can do it I I'm a writer so I wrote it
all down like it was a story but you can
also do it as a bullet as bullet points
and
that was one of the most powerful
experiences of my life because it really
allowed me this opportunity to see
where all of my ideas about how
relationships are and what they're
supposed to be like where all of that
came from and where I needed to take
accountability for myself
and my part in everything I had done
throughout my life
and that was a big task and it was
[__] completely revelatory and
psychedelic and transformative sure it's
almost like saying things out loud you
know when you have to say them out loud
it holds it sort of releases a different
energy we can think things think things
and then as soon as you have to say it
out loud you start crying when you tell
someone or whatever like writing it out
and then rereading your story and
deducing it down to 20 Pages or whatever
your whole life and then you go oh [__]
that's pretty obvious
yes oh so going back circling back again
to your question I realized that my
entire football career
was about me proving to the world how
big and scary and to be feared
and strong I was
why
because I was scared
yeah for sure you need to overcompensate
you wanted to felt like I wasn't enough
inner child that was scared to death
yeah of the drama and the chaos exactly
that was a big thing that I recognized
going back to what did I
turn off and
recognizing why am I doing things why am
I choosing to do the things that I do in
my life that Clarity of understanding
where that whole where my mission to
play in the NFL it was never rooted in
the fact that I loved football I mean I
was the same it was never really about
racing when you get to that place that
you you realize that you almost like I
feel bad I feel like I feel guilty in
some way or like a fraud in some way but
it's not true because it's there's a lot
of athletes that don't necessarily love
the sport they love aspects of the sport
and that's how I was it's totally true
it was very true for me and I saw
there's a clip going around on social
media I think it's a guy on the Jags I
follow the Jags and the Bears I played
for those teams he's a d tackle for the
Jags and his quote is to be honest with
you I don't even really like football I
just like hitting people yeah there you
go I'm sure I was at a game then I think
I went to a game I'm from the Chicago
area I'm from Roscoe Illinois which is
like right on the state line about an
hour or so from Chicago and so I have a
house in Chicago still
um I love that I love Chicago I love
Chicago so much I I don't go there
nearly enough
um but uh but I probably went to a game
in 2012. you were probably playing for
the Bears in 12.
do all those filled with the Jags 13 I
was on the Bears and 13 and 14 I was on
the Bears okay maybe maybe I did maybe I
did but anyway I've always been a Bears
fan and then I had a momentary
other team and then
who is the other team the Packers I
because I dated Aaron oh
okay I forgot about that yeah that's why
I know even more about football
even though I already knew a lot about
football that's why you're saying the
other team yeah you know but it is the
other team from the Bears uh-huh yeah it
is no you're totally right I was
wondering a while ago when you were
talking about having so much rage in you
and you know especially after you were
done and when you had the CBD company
and telling that part of the story and
you know CTE being obviously something
that you know those of us who wore
helmets when we did what we did
um and that you had said that through
yoga and mushrooms and probably
meditation I'm guessing was probably
part of that that you feel like you've
sort of reprogrammed yourself
so I'm wondering because I mean that's
one of the powers of of psilocybin is
the neuroplasticity of it like the
creating new neural Pathways so do you
think do you think you had CTE do you
and then obviously you know speak to the
mushrooms and you know what the power of
those were and what you really felt like
it helped you do there was definitely a
time in my career like I said right
before the Adderall came in where I was
living in a a fog and I've experienced
concussions looking back I never
reported a concussion ever in my
football career and then it wasn't until
I was maybe a couple years out and I
started thinking about it and I realized
how many concussions I had
and
how
there were
super specific
memories I have of
taking a hit in practice or there being
a collision with a linebacker in
practice that left me in a dark hole for
three four days afterwards which I
self-medicated with cannabis and
I would say cannabis is also probably
one of the most important things as far
as neuroprotectants goes
not only the CBD but the THC as well
that's been that was a big part of
coming out of football cannabis advocacy
and talking about cannabis as medicine
for football players and
it was a whole like
other part of my life honestly that's
sort of what started me
in my journey out of football because it
gave me this way to speak about the
truth of my experience in an effort to
enlightened and illuminate these
darker parts of being an athlete playing
football the NFL Etc
um
and
I've always had this curiosity in with
plant medicine since I was
probably a teenager I mean I started
just thinking about
and being curious of
everything from Cannabis to peyote and
cannabis I experimented with like as a
teenager and it was hard to do also
because you're getting drug tested and I
had to be mindful of that and I was
always a team captain and was terrified
of being you know testing positive and
getting in trouble started speaking
about cannabis's medicine and then that
really
in my life after football I was given
you know this
opportunity to just start playing with
things and learning and studying and
researching and
going into that Curiosity more and so
I don't even really know how
that started other than I just have
always looked at myself as sort of a a
lab rat and
I experiment on myself with these things
and
I started taking mushrooms
started taking LSD and did combo which
is the yeah
is that the one hour stuff like the drop
the frog frog poison that yeah they
throw up for an hour they burn it yeah
they burn the shaman burns the top layer
of skin off and then spackles in this
frog Venom and you have this intense how
many dot scars do how many dots do you
have on you there's a lot I don't know
20 30 something like that oh [__] oh wow
you're like can you make a great design
of this uh they did they did you can
still see it
at times in certain light they did a
cool like
diamond shape on my shoulder which is
pretty fun
uh combo is
amazing for me it was super important
maybe one of the most powerful medicines
I've done I mean I just heard you purge
like toxins but I don't know about the
Psychedelic nature of it I haven't tried
that one well you're purging everything
you're purging emotions and thoughts
it's a whole it's a purge of your entire
being that's how you lost so much weight
after football
no I was on I was super
you're hilarious
no that was that was a whole other part
of my journey with keto and all this
other stuff but that is an interesting
question though because it actually
brings me to
my process coming out of football and it
started with okay
I'm gonna get my physical body in order
I've been wanting I've wanted to lose
this weight
you know I do there's no need for me to
be 320 pounds anymore such a great way
to step into taking care of yourself too
like I think that's actually a really
great Gateway for most all people when
they are really self-abandoning to start
just working out and just making that a
priority because when you when you how
you do the little things is then how you
do the big things and so when you start
practicing taking care of yourself it's
a can be a pretty big Cascade effect in
life yeah that was huge for me and as an
athlete it was intuitive and where I
knew I could start I thought to myself
I'm gonna get this physical body in
order let me get my food super dialed in
I'm gonna get into the best shape of my
life and then
was only through that process did the
chaos of my mental experience become
really clear I was like oh oh there's
like this stuff going on now you know
like I got my physical body in order but
there's a whole [__] thing about how
I relate to myself in the world that's
that needs adjustment and that was
really when my life started to crash
over me and I came to a complete rock
bottom and
felt like I could I couldn't look at
myself in the mirror and it was just
time for me to be gone or change my life
completely I came into Al-Anon which
brought me to therapy which brought me
to meditation
which led me to some of truly my great
mentors of my life guy named Kirk
Westwood
guy named Joshua Darnell two of them
both medicine men in their own rights
um
Kirk brought me into combo him and Josh
brought me into Ayahuasca and meeting
these men
gave me the green light to start
tuning in to
my truth my Curiosities
my
building my own way of being and was it
helpful that they were men is this why
like I saw that you're doing you do some
you do men's group stuff and
um is that is it the fact that you had
these very strong but yet
in touch sort of and calm and in control
men you had a good model now all of a
sudden it gave you permission
yes big time it's funny you say that too
it's reminding me of this book iron John
by Robert Bly I'm throwing out some good
book recommendations especially for the
men
the men listeners this book iron John by
Robert Bly Robert Bly is a poet he's
also
one of the most profound thinkers
philosophers on masculinity and
fatherhood and my brother turned me on
to him
a few years ago
probably around covid and just listening
to his talks on fatherhood and manhood
and masculinity and
this book ironed John
is a really important book for men to
read and it talks about there's a
there's a great mythology of the wild
man the wild man archetype which is
essentially
archetypal character that is the Gateway
for all men
into their soul into their Divine
masculinity because the wild man is not
interested in any external thing any
external success
finances material
the wild man is truly interested in the
happenings of the soul the low down deep
dark dirty
thick yeah well the wild man is also
usually solo right yes and there's a
beautiful story about the wild man which
I don't know how much time we have but
I'll save you have to read the book but
he talks about in there because he goes
into all of the ancient traditions and
Indigenous tribes and the bringing up of
the young boys and the the rituals and
the manhood and these things
yeah go ahead and finish and I have a
question these things that we lack in
our in modern day Society or at least in
the west and one of the things he talks
about in there which I connected with in
a moment was
at some point
the young man is initiated into his
manhood by something
some experience that he has
if you're lucky
because right for me I was lucky in that
I came out of football and my initiation
was [__] peeling back the layers and
[Music]
learning about who I was on the inside
like that
that whole process was an initiation for
me into manhood
and I could have completely crumbled you
know I could have completely left that
and gone the other way
but so after the young man has
experienced a an initiation of sorts and
come into His manhood he meets his male
mother for me it was These Guys these
mentors because it's giving you the
nurturing of your manhood from the man
and there's a lot of tribes where
like the young boys will be taken away
from the mothers and they'll just go and
live with the men for you know the next
decade of their lives to learn about oh
yeah and I tell you what when you see
like single family households and when
there isn't a man there isn't yes ground
is
it's not ideal man it's not it's not
good no it's not ideal it's not that
women can't raise great human beings but
there is something very special about
having a man in the house what could be
an important rite of passage that
transitions a boy to a man and what age
should that happen at I'll just tell you
this the the Snippets of the story of
the wild man
and
this will give you some idea and there's
this Forest on the edge of a kingdom
and every day Hunters go into this
forest and they never come out again so
the king of this Kingdom
he shuts down access to the force he's
like can't go in there [__] that can't
go in there anymore people won't come
out of that Forest
so one day a young hunter from out of
town comes in
comes to the king and he says hey
I'm here I'm looking for an adventure
give me something dangerous to do
what do you got the King goes well
there's a forest at the edge of the
Kingdom that nobody ever comes out of
he's like great I got it the young
Hunter goes in there
unarmed with just his dog
and he's walking through the forest
and they come upon this little Pond and
the young Hunter just takes no to the
pond he's super cool he's collected he's
just like observing the surroundings and
all of a sudden out of the corner of his
eye he sees this hand come out of the
pond and snatch his dog and bring it
under and he doesn't freak out obviously
he's a little upset that his dog's in
the pond but he just walks out of the
forest
he goes and gathers a few men and they
get their buckets
you get Buckets and they come back into
the forest they find the pond they start
emptying the ponds of all the water and
at the bottom of the pond is this wild
man he's covered in air his dog's there
he's he's totally
alone he's
aloof they capture him
they bring him back into the kingdom
they say this is the guy that's been
causing all your problems they put him
in a cage in the center of town now the
king locks the cage and he gives the key
to the queen and the queen holds the key
under her pillow
so one day The Little Prince
the young boy The Little Prince he's
playing with his Golden Ball
and of course he's in the center of town
where the wild man is and the ball
bounces and rolls and it rolls into the
cage of the wild man
and the little boy's like oh boy I gotta
go I gotta go engage with this wild
beast that's in this cage so he gathers
up the courage and he goes to the wild
man he says Hey can I have my golden
ball back and the wild man says yeah of
course but you have to let me out of the
cage first
and the little boy goes uh I can't do
that I don't I can't let you out I'll be
in trouble
every man every boy has this moment
where we come into contact with this
thing that we know we're not supposed to
do or we feel like we're not supposed to
do it because of our parents or our
programming
and we resist it we back away we're like
uh I can't do that right now eventually
at some point
you come back to the wild man because
you're like I just want my [__] ball
back so I'm gonna get you your I'm going
to get you out of here
the only thing is we gotta figure out
where is the key we've forgotten at this
point it's been so long
that we've forgotten where the key is
and then we remember the key is
underneath our mother's pillow oh yeah
but the trick is we can't just go ask
for the key because our mother doesn't
want us to grow up our mother doesn't
really want us
to become a man they want us to stay the
little boy her baby that she can care
for and take care of
and the King doesn't want us letting the
wild man out of the out of the cage
because then he's like the Ultimate
Weapon against Authority he's completely
disconnected from oh yeah yeah he's not
he's not following along
so this story is essentially that we
have to steal the key to let the Wild
Man Out Of The Cage
to get our golden ball back initially
but what we don't realize is really it's
about letting the Wild Man Out Of The
Cage
the key
exactly stealing the key the wild man is
the representation of our divine
masculinity right
so the stealing the key portion is what
is really crucial now Robert Bly talks
about he would do these men's groups and
he said one night he watched this sort
of nerdy young guy
drunkenly dance
at the after party of the workshop and
he just saw this guy like really like
change and transform and he got into his
body and sort of let everything go and
the next day the kid came to him and he
was like hey I think I stole some of
that key back last night
and he said okay
and Robert Bly realized that the
stealing of the key is a really
interesting aspect of
stepping into your Divine masculinity
because it has to do with
essentially going against the grain of
society or freeing yourself from the
constraints of programming that could be
dancing drunkenly at your cousin's
wedding that could be breaking the
chains of a family bond in a
dysfunctional behavior that could be
standing up for yourself at work that
could be
ending a relationship that wasn't
working for you anymore so these are all
initiations in the modern world that men
are going through all the time but it
takes courage and it takes
it takes a certain amount of you got to
be like [__] it I'm done living this way
right I'm going to make a change
and that's when we begin the process of
really tapping into our divine
masculinity information or pain like you
said it's coming from inspiration or
pain to change exactly wow that's a cool
story thank you for sharing that that
makes so much sense I'm curious I want
to Loop in sort of the female side just
a little because I'm eternally
fascinated with sort of the masculine
feminine balance just with the nature of
what I did and just my life and
everything it's like it's very it's
quite the puzzle
and so I'm curious being you know a man
that's done so much work and and come to
a a place where you can teach about it
about this this inherent balance that
you've found
um what is it that that man wants in a
woman like what is when what role do you
want to play because I don't think the
archetypal sort of man is still like not
the man it's still not something it's
not that that's not a wonderful thing
like a woman loves to be taken care of
Take Charge you know lead like there are
there are things that a woman feels
really good to be in relationship with
so what is it that you want in a woman
and what role what what is the role as
the masculine that you want in the
relationship I've been in
relationships where that was completely
out of balance and it was something that
I had to really
take accountability for in my own life
and
let's attempt to Define
the man the male the masculine entity in
a relationship yeah it's the mountain
the mountain is Rock Solid it's
unshakable people live on the mountain
things grow on the mountain
it's creating this container or this
structure for the divine feminine to
move and grow out of and prosper and
create from now that takes for a man to
become the mountain
takes
being Rock Solid on the inside being
unshakable on the inside which comes
down to having reconciled your Darkness
which is a big part of the wild man
ethos that that narrative is that you're
reconciling the dark
grotesque stuff inside of you that's in
all of us we all have these things that
we really don't want to look at that are
too ugly to put out there into the world
but what's important is that we
reconcile with it on the inside and so
to be the man who can show up as the
masculine entity in a relationship
you must have done that you must do that
now another important part of
relationships is that we're not going
into a relationship thinking about the
fact that this person is going to give
me something this person is going to
fill the hole inside
that I need filling you know what I mean
like this person is not going to make me
the person I think I'm supposed to be
I'm coming into this relationship as the
person I am supposed to be and I'm being
in this relationship once again why are
we doing anything why are we taking
making the decisions we're making living
the way we are is it because we're
trying to get something or is it because
it is what we really desire and want and
it fills us
it's because of love it's because of
this undeniable attraction or undeniable
urge to spend our life with a person Etc
so then the feminine is
the creative the the Whimsical it's the
crashing ocean Against The Cliff it's
the wind it's all of it's the water it's
all of this stuff that's fluid and
moving and ever
spontaneously just the rain life things
happening yeah exactly
um and you think about that from
you know a super esoteric point of view
the masculine is always defined in in
art or in structure as like the phallic
symbol this it's a structure
it's a structure and The Feminine is the
void it's the vastness of all creation
it's the space around the structure
so
for me you know it it I [__] this up
big time in all of my past relationships
because I was too much you know and it
had a lot to do with my football career
and
having Ultra focus on my sport as an
athlete
I was super apathetic when it came to
just about everything else in my life I
was like uh where do you want to eat you
know those types of decisions like
everything got thrown to my partner
and that in that went from the small
decisions of what are we going to have
tonight for dinner too the big decisions
of like
what are we going to do with our
daughter where is she going to go to
school is it private public
you know are we gonna
get our French Bulldog fixed which you
know we did and he [__] died and it
was because I didn't trust my instincts
and I just went with the flow you know
and I didn't set a boundary I didn't
speak my truth and that was a big lesson
for me
in that and looking back on my marriage
I had to go man I failed as a father I
failed as as a male because
for too long we established I didn't
establish leadership and not that it
would have been dominating but it would
have been involved and
creating a structure of understanding of
us being on the same page sure sure like
something to respect you know there's
exactly lean on if you don't show that
you have an opinion at any point in time
how can I let you have any of them
because I just have to make them all the
time anyway and so for a woman to be
able to just like let her guard down and
relax and get vulnerable and be like I'm
exhausted can you just handle it I can't
do that yes you're always just saying
whatever you want and you all of a
sudden take the role yeah okay I guess I
do everything
so then you force I've I
unintentionally unconsciously
pushed my partner into a position where
she had to completely assume the
masculine yeah Essence she had to live
as the masculine yeah you know so
that was a really big experience for me
in understanding what my manhood
actually means like what is my
masculinity oh
it's about being the [__] like being
the king
being the leader is about creating the
boundaries it's about creating the
structure that the people exist within
and that doesn't mean that you're just
like judge jury and executioner but
you're creating a tangible
Kingdom
that we can all exist in because there's
a level of understanding and we're all
on the same page about what is what are
What's the culture you're establishing
the culture of the relationship
so exactly like you said you know as a
woman how is a woman supposed to
feel like she can just settle into her
femininity
if she's got to be in charge of
every single decision that's being made
throughout the day you know about the
life the day which becomes about the
life having that stop
and really learned
the you know the counter action of all
of that stuff of how to show up as the
man
as the masculine force in the
relationships that I'm in in the
relationship I'm in now I see how that
allows my partner to be the woman that
she wants to be the mother the nurturing
supportive creative
inspired divine feminine being that she
desires to be
and I think if that if that stuff is out
of whack and it comes down to a moment
by moment experience of if something is
happening that feels out of alignment or
out of sorts we have to address it right
here right now because otherwise it's
going to become this [__]
thing that we're holding resentments and
we're moving in in silence you know that
when you're in a relationship with
somebody and you know something's wrong
oh yeah like doing the dishes and right
you're like Meandering around each other
in the kitchen and yeah you know you're
like I'm not grabbing your butt anymore
and you're like great
isn't going well
so
I think for me
I I mean I feel I I haven't talked about
this much on a pod but since we've gone
here Danica I'm uh you know it feels
like it's time to say it which is uh
I've really found myself in a
relationship where I'm with
my complete soul mate who's the love of
my life and it's like beyond anything I
could have ever imagined a relationship
being
and that was only possible because I
[__] healed myself on the inside
first and then I didn't come into a
relationship looking for something or
putting something on this person about
who they are or what they're supposed to
be like
I think that it feels good when that
masculine feminine thing is in balance
and you know every day there's like
there's things that come up where
you know I get into my feminine she gets
into her masculine but then it's always
coming back to this what's the big
picture of the relationship like who's
where and where do we find ourselves and
what are the roles of of what we're
doing
with each other
for ourselves
and together you know
um and I think that every man but this
is you know this is because we're it's
difficult to speak
every healed man who's living in his
masculinity who's who's living
in the truth of his manhood
I I believe you're looking for a woman
who is
anchored in her femininity obviously and
what does that mean to me that means
loving supportive encouraging
creative
I don't know I mean it's another thing
it's difficult to articulate there's a
lot about it all that's very ineffable
and and quite
energetic as opposed to something that
language is able to
um explain yes yes you just feel it like
love you can't really even describe what
love is right like that's not even
something that's so easy to describe you
definitely can't prove it well you know
that's not something there's no
scientific proof of that yet it's
probably the most powerful force out
there there's no doubt about it and uh I
would say you know if you're trying to
put words to what love is it's
like true love is this the first thing
that comes into my mind is total
acceptance but it's even beyond that
because there's this
really delicious warm acceptance isn't
quite it it's more because there was
anything that you don't accept yeah so
it's uh it's my my very spiritual
experience I had many years ago was that
Beyond us it's all love and that there's
no need for forgiveness because there
was never a judgment in the first place
so acceptance is is sort of implying
something unacceptable and it's not that
when you really love someone there's
actually anything unacceptable you just
love them no matter what yes exactly
yeah oh wow
well thank you so much man that was such
a great way of articulating that and and
especially just driving home sort of
like the the core of what's helped you
anchor into your masculinity which has
given you this ability to have this
incredible balance in life and be able
to and you know have love for yourself
and others and a way that you've never
felt before so congratulations
thank you Danica I appreciate it thank
you so much thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button